before that you guys go and have you I
need to ask as well just because you're
both like lauded designers of various
first-person shooter games have you
played uh-uh not less overwatch actually
interested have you played doom
fantastic campaign right yeah I mean
yeah do you think they intentionally
scuff the multiplayer because they had
that quake thing look man oh god I I
criticize my friends at eid microsoft
and everything because I care like yeah
as Nintendo because i care i was called
the kind of boys a child my thing about
the new it'd and I knew I saw this my
wife used to work he did software she
was a bill manager back in the day at
seven years ago she was working on rage
when i first started writer and went on
and I rage came out in great campaign
absolutely stunning like some weird like
pseudo Mad Max car racing mario kart
multiplayer yeah this is its software
this is the company that [ __ ]
invented deathmatch like you better
deliver some awesome death match and I
played the early alpha of the do
multiplayer and it wasn't bad but after
30 minutes I'm like okay I get the idea
yeah you know you can turn it into a
demon like no I want to be shooting
rocket launchers and people in my my
death match and dude right so the
campaign had so much love and I think
machinegames worked on that you know
it's just critical oh yeah got something
to tell you yeah that's the whole thing
is you know like it and then I think
it's actually acknowledged that they're
taking it in house but you know
business-wise I'm like that might be too
little too late guys you know like you
should have you know done that initially
and like again you know when you put out
a disk space game people just trading
games now right yeah so by the time you
know the multiplayer gets you know
updated for them people may have moved
on to the next Call of Duty or maybe
lawbreakers of god knows what yeah I'll
tell you man that campaign is just its
crunchy its the weapons are amazing the
levels looks so good and they did such a
good job of balancing you know when
you're inside kind of the claustrophobic
basis to kind of being on the the
Martian surface in particle effects
Albans it's just really really good it's
real good time for first-person shooters
and you guys are coming out with one
real soon when can people get on the
Alpha for lawbreakers on the 18th this
weekend also a Saturday and Sunday well
you know it's closed off we go to
lawbreakers calm sign up we distributed
a bunch of keys if you see us at e3 my
wife and I are handing out the and sorry
Anya the little cards with the key on it
it's on Steam enter the code hop online
you know it's got a little bit of a
learning curve we're starting with one
map one mode grandview the Grand Canyon
map is
well as the capture the battery mode
overcharge and then in early July the
promenade map and tours coming online
and more and more stuffs going to keep
happening until we get to the point
where you flip the switch and actually
say hey you know we'd like to keep the
studio going if you'd like to give us a
few bucks right and that'll probably be
20 17 I'm guessing no late 2016 oh
really that happen yep you guys have a
large price point somewhere between
twenty to forty dollars haven't
determined that yet you know we're not
gonna make a multiplayer only game and
ask you for 60 bucks and that's [ __ ]
cool beans cliff Kaczynski are John the
Bruce a pleasure had to talk to you both
in bosque studios best of luck with the
rest of it and yeah you can keep those
airheads you permission you've earned
them we'll be back in just a minute
folks or a bit of a shifting gears here
from first person to hot strategy games
we've got Hitler wars 2 coming up in a
little bit but first of all dawn dawn of
war 3 back in few minutes